c'est encore une histoire de héros
ordinaires comme dans ce lit ce pilote
qui avait évité un autre traumatisme new
yorkais en se posant dans le besoin
sauf que là ça ne se passe pas dans un
avion mais dans un train
et là aussi c'est une histoire vraie
évidemment carnage a été évité de
justesse un carnage éviter dans le train
qui relie bruxelles à paris l'assaillant
comme on le voit sur cette animation a
été maîtrisé après avoir fait trois
blessés
l'animation est devenu aujourd'hui un
long métrage au cinéma sous l'oeil de
clint eastwood
mais ce sont ceux qui ont vécu la scène
qui la jouent en vedette les trois
américains qui sont devenus des héros le
monde entier admire votre courage ils
racontent partout à quel point tout est
semblable à la réalité sans titre exact
mais il ya un petit problème avec le
calendrier de sortie du film parce que
comme le disait jean françois bélanger
l' enquête a été ajoutée a confié au
parquet antiterroriste de paris
et cette enquête elle n'est pas terminée
l'avocate qui défend l'assaillant
réclamait une reconstitution depuis des
mois la justice vient de lui refuser ce
qui lui inspire ce si l'industrie
hollywoodienne qui délivre sa vérité
avant celle de l'institution judiciaire
quant au résultat sur grand écran
c'est à voir ce vendredi
si mathieu prost radio canada